a lot has changed this year we've got a
worldwide pandemic
we're all stuck working from home so why
not make the most out of your time at
home
that's why today we're talking about the
top 10 technologies you should learn in
2021
so let's get started with number 10
blockchain
blockchain the tech behind bitcoin has
so much more to offer than just
cryptocurrencies
it has become a major combatant to deep
fakes and fake news
by fingerprinting the video at source it
leaves a trail that can be traced back
easily we are seeing a widespread
adoption of blockchain for transactions
as it removes the need for an
intermediary and improved security
organizations like action factom axon
enterprises
and darpa are currently working on a
number of blockchain applications
the global blockchain market is expected
to grow from three billion dollars in
2020
to 39.7 billion dollars by 2025
with a cagr of 67.3
during 2020 to 2025. to get into
blockchain you need to be experienced
with programming languages
the fundamentals of oops flat and
relational database
data structures web app development and
networking
next up at number 9 quantum computing it
is a form of computing that takes
advantage of quantum phenomena like
superposition and quantum entanglement
it is also involved in preventing the
spread of coronavirus
and to develop potential vaccines thanks
to its ability to easily query
monitor analyze and act on data
regardless of the source
in banking and finance quantum computing
would help manage credit risk
for high frequency trading and fraud
detection quantum computers are now
thousands of times faster than regular
computers
organizations like splunk honeywell
microsoft
aws google and many others are now
involved in making innovations in the
field of quantum computing the revenues
for the global quantum computing market
are projected to surpass 2.5 billion
dollars by 2029.
to get into quantum computing you need
to have experience with quantum
mechanics
linear algebra probability information
theory and machine learning
now at number eight we have 5g the
technology of 3g
and 4g have enabled us to browse the
internet use data-driven services
increase bandwidths for streaming on
spotify or youtube and so much more
similarly 5g services are expected to
revolutionize our lives
by enabling services that rely on
advanced technologies like ar and vr
alongside cloud-based gaming services
like google stadia
nvidia geforce now and much more 5g is
expected to be used in factories
hd cameras that help improve safety and
traffic management
smart grid control and smart retail just
about every telecom company like verizon
t-mobile apple nokia corp qualcomm are
now working on creating 5g applications
5g services are expected to launch
worldwide in 2021 with more than 50
operators offering services in about 30
countries by the end of 2021 next
number 7 the internet of things in 2021
iot would evolve into the intelligence
of things as more and more devices
become ai enabled
iot software and hardware applications
are expected to see great growth
thanks to changing industry dynamics
economic stimulus and remote access
demand
iot is expected to be adopted by smart
manufacturing and healthcare and
is expected to bring about industry 4.0
ai enabled medical iot devices can have
applications like clinical
decision-making
thermal image recognition surgical
assistance
smart clinics and telemedicine centers
companies like sap
siemens ibm huawei and cisco are
all currently working on making all new
iot applications
it is expected that there will be 35
billion iot devices
installed worldwide by 2021 and 75.44
billion by 2025.
to get started with iot you need to
learn about information security
ai and machine learning networking
hardware interfacing
business intelligence tools and ux slash
ui design
next up number six cyber security given
the current scenario and for a while to
come
cyber security is going to be a major
focus for many organizations
there would be an increased focus on
protecting smaller organizations from
cyber attacks
protecting the identities and devices of
remote workers
preventing access to confidential
patient records
protecting smart supply chains and so
much more the need for proper cyber
security is so high that
according to cyber crime magazine it is
expected that by 2021 6 trillion dollars
will be spent globally on
cyber security some of the major players
within this industry are fortinet
cisco microsoft splunk palo alto
networks
and so on to get started with cyber
security you'll need
skills like i.t and network fundamentals
coding skills
cloud security and malware analysis next
up at number five we have augmented
virtuality and extended reality in 2021
we can expect these forms of
technologies being further
integrated into our lives usually
working in tandem with some of the other
technologies we've mentioned in the list
ar and vr is expected to play a huge
role in the field of healthcare
by providing training simulations to
help medical professionals and for
opticians to perform eye tests
it is also to play a huge role in the
educational sector
greatly improving the interactivity the
vr video and gaming market is expected
to grow to 2.9 and 2 billion
in 2021 respectively snap microsoft
atnt and nexus studios are some of the
major companies working towards
ar and vr you need skills like software
development
ar vr maintenance support design slash
graphics and hardware engineering to
work in this sector at number four
we have dark dark is an emerging
technology that several major industries
have their sights on
dark is a combination of distributed
ledger technology
artificial intelligence extended reality
and quantum computing
accenture who introduced dark beliefs
that these technologies combined could
have an enormous
impact on technology as a whole dark is
now primarily geared towards the
healthcare industry
where it is expected to lower the cost
of care improve labor productivity and
enable better experiences for consumers
and partners
due to its currently developing nature
only a few organizations have started
taking advantage of this technology to
get into dark
you'll need skills related to each of
its contributing technologies like dlt
ai xr and quantum computing next up at
number three
as a service cloud services are expected
to provide even more services that make
technology like ai and robotics
accessible to every business
thanks to companies like google
microsoft amazon a number of startups
and innovators
cutting-edge technology is accessible to
everyone with little investment
serverless computing is also something
that's being focused on as it provides
users the opportunity to work on the
core product without operating and
managing the servers
hybrid cloud is also expected to show
great growth thanks to its speed
ease of control and security options the
global iaas
paas and saas market size is supposed to
grow to 81 billion dollars
72 billion dollars and 140.6 billion us
dollars respectively to get into cloud
computing you'll need to have an
understanding of the concepts like
different cloud computing platforms
programming languages specialize on
services belonging to compute
storage database domains and so on now
let's talk about number two
automation with an increasing number of
potential cases
initiatives towards self-driving
vehicles would be a priority for civic
authorities and many other organizations
across the world
this ensures that the cost of human
labor is reduced and handles customer
demand there would also be an increase
in the incorporation of robots in the
care and assisted living sectors
robotic devices are also expected to
provide companionship to elderly people
drones are also expected to be
incorporated for the delivery of
medicine
groceries and other essential goods some
of the popular companies in the field of
automation are siemens
honeywell abb and mitsubishi to get into
automation you will need skills like
programming skills and scripting skills
configuration management software an
understanding of testing tools and so on
and finally at number one
artificial intelligence ai is a field
that's expected to see the most amount
of growth in the next year
ai can help interpret and understand the
enormous amount of content produced
machine learning algorithms would become
better informed and perform much more
sophisticated operations
it is expected to be used to analyze
interactions to determine underlying
connections and insights
to help predict demand for services like
hospitals
and enable authorities to make better
decisions about resource utilization
ai will be used by businesses to detect
the changing patterns of customer
behavior
and for detecting the various ways they
can be satisfied global
spending on cognitive and ai systems is
expected to reach 57.6
billion dollars by 2021 and to get into
ai you'll need skills like programming
languages
linear algebra probability big data
machine learning algorithms etc on that
note why don't you check out
simplylearn's postgraduate program on ai
and machine learning
created in partnership with purdue
university and in collaboration with ibm
we'll cover a number of topics and
concepts like statistics
python machine learning deep learning
networks
nlp reinforcement learning and much more
to help you grow
in your career and there you go guys
that's our top 10 technologies to learn
in 2021
with that we've reached the end of this
video do you think there's something
even more amazing than ai
let us know in the comment section below
thank you for watching the video
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
you